redwood city scrubs black lives matter
mural
after trump supporter asks to paint
maga20 maga2020 on same street
on the same it was in the same spot wait
wait i'm sorry i'm just
before we were before we read any
further i would like to give a pseudo
standing ovation
to this individual come on a little bit
all right i'm actually
i'm pretty impressed this is the most
i'm pretty impressed
this is amazing you see here listen
listen
we know every everybody you've been
hearing about um bevel and beady right
that's her name
she is considered this uh maga trump
hero
because she's been splashing paint in
the black lives matter murals
and then you know talking about how they
don't actually care about black lives
she's a trump supporter she's saying
things like jesus matters and jesus
christ is his name
yeah i have respect for what she's doing
because she's engaging in non-violent
civil disobedience that's true
whereas normally i would say i don't
like
i would i would actually condemn the
splashing of paint so long as they're
allowing antifa to spray paint
you know buildings and statues and then
calling them peaceful protesters
then why would i complain about what
beverly's doing right it's like
it's a good point if these are the
standards we're abiding by what do you
want me to say
however maybe she should try spray paint
instead of of dumping paint
because maybe it's specifically spray
paint they allowed
just letting you know well just saying
this is the smartest thing
period yeah because i i've said uh over
and over
the correct way to deal with this is to
simply assert your equal rights under
the law
if they write black lives matter then
you should be able to write all lives
matter right next to it
of course they're not going to want to
do that yeah so sure enough
some very uh smart trump supporters said
okay
i want to paint maga and they were like
get rid of it get rid of it take it down
and they get rid of it instead however i
believe this trump supporter should
still file a lawsuit demanding their
right to do it
because black lives matter was already
painted oh they got rid of it
yeah so they scrubbed the they got rid
of it they got rid of the mural for
black lives matter because they didn't
want maga on the streets
oh okay yes that's why i'm clapping i'm
like
that's amazing however they already
wrote
black lives matter therefore they have
already made the streets a public forum
and this individual still has the right
to say maga 2020 on the street they
can't reject him now
wow period that's a good point sue or
you could see this judicial watch is
suing
they want quote because no one is above
the law written on dc
streets because they wrote black lives
matter not only that i say you go one
step further
for every street that's been renamed
black lives matter i think you should
sue
and say you want to rename a street all
lives matter or hey how about maga2020
or simply just lives matter no no the
point if you need a color in front of
that
then you have an issue if they're going
to to write
a political message on street names yep
and in the streets then anyone should be
allowed to do the exact same thing
so they want to make black lives matter
plaza i got no beef i'm not going to say
like i disagree with this
with the paint they got their street i'm
happy for you congratulations
i love it that's good for you yeah now
i'm gonna get my street
i'm gonna make uh how about i say you
know uh
um tim pool for president how about i
get i want that i want that in the
street don't tease us man
i want that in front i want that in new
york city i want mayor bill de blasio to
use taxpayer money to write
tim pool is the best political message
i want to see that they have they have
to allow it right
what what's their defense going to be in
court we only allow
our political message that's that's what
they're i mean we'll
they may i can't wait to see what they
have to say actually honestly
they made streets a public speech forum
you're right and they can't deny people
now it's true
even trying to get rid of it's not going
to be enough check it out they say
many communities across the country are
displaying black lives matter street
murals
redwood city was one of them until last
week when the city quietly removed it
redwood city resident dan peace got
permission from city officials to paint
black lives matter sign on broadway as
part of the 4th of july public art
celebration
the city even supplied him with yellow
poster board paint to do it
well they're paying for it too well now
you got to pay for my paint to write my
message
because we were using the poster board
paint that would eventually deteriorate
over time
my understanding from them was that the
mural would last as long as the paint
lasted
but last thursday the city washed the
sign away after being contacted by a
local real estate attorney
maria ruttenberg who said that if the
street was now a public forum
she wanted a sign of her own reading
2020.
standing ovation to you maria to you
i saw black lives matter sign appearing
on broadway street on the asphalt and i
figured
that's going to be new public space open
for discussion and i wanted to get my
message out too
yep brilliant maga is of course short
for make america great again a rallying
cry for supporters of trump
faced with the possibility of a
political and or legal fight
the city suddenly decided that dan
peace's sign was a traffic hazard
that might cause accidents and they
removed it in the middle of the night
peace says he doesn't consider black
lives matter to be a political statement
but he understands the position the city
was in it doesn't matter if it's a
political statement to you what matters
is it was speech
period if i paint anything even an
abstract picture of outer space
that is speech and therefore anyone can
write
anything they open the door for this and
washing that away will not change that
fact
boom i have no hard feelings to the city
council piece said
i am disappointed but at the same time i
am very grateful that they allowed me to
put that message on broadway
and there it is they let me put that
message on broadway
scrub it away all you like i hope that
this real estate
agent is maria yep carry on it is still
a public forum
erasing it doesn't change the fact that
the door has been opened
well i'm just going to say this right
now maria ruttenberg thank you
and you've opened the door and the minds
of many other people that
want to put their message out there so
this is a matter i think this is just
the beginning
this is a matter of free speech not
political support for anybody boom
if you want to write black lives matter
in the street i think the city should
not permit it because that would open up
the street to literally everybody
what happens now if someone decides to
write the 14 words the city can't say no
congratulations you did this new york
someone can go to new york right now and
say i want the 14 words across you know
50 seconds
you know uh street or whatever i want it
right in front of central park on
billionaires row
the 14 words you know that is no the
nazi slogan oh wow
and what are they gonna say no too bad i
know
i'm taking the extreme stance on this
one that's the fact
when you make the street a public forum
this is what you've done and that's why
i thought it was a bad idea
now this woman writing wanting maga on
the street i'm not saying that to
support trump or maga i'm saying to
support the first amendment in equality
under the law
freedom of speech baby this was a huge
mistake but every single jurisdiction
who has done this has opened the door
that cannot be closed
the moment the paint touched that ground
with your permission
and in some instances they paid for it
you that means
they're gonna have to pay for it too
that's a good point you can be like i
want
i wanted the president yep i wanted to
say trump 2020
and you're paying for it i wanted to say
the wall and i want you to pay for it
and then you can tell your friends we
got the wall done and they paid for it
that's good so all it takes now is any
one person now i'll tell you what
imagine if a hundred people a hundred
people all threatened to sue
yep the city would be in serious trouble
any one of these cities
all of these cities imagine if a
thousand people yep and guess what
it's a first amendment issue it's
national it's not citywide yeah meaning
anyone from anywhere should legally be
able to do it
i could be wrong i'm not a lawyer okay
wait
she oh she's she's an attorney she's a
real estate attorney right oh okay
she's a real estate attorney that's what
it is yeah yeah real estate attorney
does it say that though for sure it says
right there local real estate attorney
so she seems to know what she's on about
yeah so think about it
i'm curious as to how many bored people
there are
and how many streets we are going to see
over the next few weeks littered with
crazy messages that make no sense
because she just did it yeah now they
quickly erased it like oh no oh no
but i don't think they can win no i
don't think they can no not at all
maybe they can people want this they're
looking for this
they are battle flying to the the
shelves to buy goya
i i know that's that's kind of like a
random thing but no it's true wait
wait hold on but look at that you know
people should should demand that goya be
written in the streets
you're right no joke no joke i agree
with you i want it
i want to see a gigantic mural of a can
of goya black beans
just straight down fifth avenue oh man
dude that would be one of the most
triggering things you could do because
it's
almost nonsensical it's true but but but
i do mean it erasing this shouldn't
change the fact
that the speech was already permitted
yep exactly they could come out and say
it was a mistake we shouldn't have
allowed it
but i think any good judge is gonna say
i get it
but you've given the speech already
right you can't take away the fact that
you've granted people the right to speak
exactly you can set a time limit i
suppose but to be fair under the law
however long that message existed anyone
should be able to write de blasio
put 27 police officers to protect
the fifth avenue one so not only
are they allowing the speech of what
they're saying
or what they're allowing they're putting
27 that's more than any other unit that
they have in new york city
27 police officers are now holding that
sign
to keep it safe whoa are there going to
be an uh
yeah are there going to be so how much
money is the are the new york residents
paying for this political message that's
a great question tim
this is a they they i'm sorry man they
made such a serious
serious tactical error on this one
agreed because now if they put 26 cops
on that
you should be able to legally argue for
the same thing
from the city yep how stupid i want to
write maca 2020 on sixth avenue
and uh i want i want 27 police officers
to protect it because people might
vandalize it yep oh they don't and they
will
yeah exactly and you know the boss is
gonna say he's gonna say nope
yup and then here come the lawsuits yep
you know what man i'm not confident that
it'll be that'll be upheld though these
these two probably take a long time
but you look look how fast they removed
the mural at the very least you might
see all these cities oh they're
addictions they were sweating what city
was this in
this is it seems like a small city yeah
redwoods where's redwood
i think it's in the bay area oh okay
california yep
if one person filed a suit they'd
probably win
i could be wrong but i think they'd win
i don't know i don't know how you argue
this to a judge
we are allowed to put up a political
message and pay for it for for this one
group but not anyone else
and yeah the judge is going to be like
you can't do that that's the first
amendment applies to everybody right
if the citizens have a right to to write
something then all citizens have a right
to write something
and if the local gov if the government
is going to be paying for it for
citizens then the government pays for it
for whatever citizens want whatever
message
yeah boom yeah it's like and and they
love to the
ream trump part for just protecting the
statues
that people were you know were defacing
ripping down
yep and now de blasio's protecting
how is it not a political statement you
know it is it doesn't matter if you
think it is or isn't correct because
it's speech you're absolutely right it
doesn't matter if it is or it isn't
it's there it's already a public forum
how many they set the precedent how many
people watch us are in new york
i wonder how many how many bored people
can spend a few minutes to file a
petition or something
i don't care what city you're in it
doesn't matter if you if you feel like
it's wrong
that they they get to write it down and
and you can't what are you waiting for
we should see a maga 2020 right next to
every black lives matter oh for sure
yeah
balance or at least all lives matter or
something but then you know what's gonna
happen
violence yep people are gonna start
fighting well hey news flash there's
already violence all over the place
people are getting shot every single day
right now
they're they're already shooting each
other people say this is happening right
now
riots have been going on non-stop for
almost two months
what this makes me super mad about new
york city because
the fact that they assigned 27 cops
yeah it's two guards 27 yeah no new york
is crazy not only that they're
they're actively telling people look
stop calling us for people doing
fireworks
go ask them yourself and then someone
got shot and then did you hear oh yeah
33 year old woman went out and said look
please please stop
and they were like all right all right
went over got a gun and killed her
it's like new york is a cesspool what
are you doing de blasio
what are you doing he's insane it's a
shame yeah dude
city should be ashamed of himself i hope
i have a dream
that one day i wake up and across this
country
are just weird nonsensical speech
statements that i don't understand
like magoya that's a great people people
are going to be like what what's magoya
it doesn't matter it's a combination of
maga and goya
but people are like america goya again
yeah yeah but people could you imagine
how like confused people are going to be
when like
one day they wake up and their black
lives matter mural is now sitting next
to magoya 2020 and they're like
what and they're going to google it
trying to figure out what it means
no one knows
it's not even about it's not even about
trump it's about literally you being
able to write
i'm cool um jim was here
yeah uh eat at joe's doesn't matter
whatever it is whatever you want
the streets are the new foreign canvas
and the city will pay for it that's
right and they'll pay to guard it
and they'll pay together as their city
falls apart wait a minute wait a minute
this might be the way to actually solve
the crime
if we write a message on every other
block right and have 27 cops
guarding each one there will be zero
that's a lot of cops
a lot of petty there'll be a lot of
citations for like jaywalking and
speeding
but that's probably like hundreds of
thousands of police
27 every other block in new york as big
as it is
it's probably hundreds of thousands yeah
it's crazy the number 27
cops because that's and i was reading
about it's like that's more than any
unit
yeah that blew my mind like a crime unit
yeah but there isn't
there isn't a crime unit that has 27
police officers and they're already
defunct
they're trying to defund the police but
using 27
police officers to protect this mural
priorities man
why i wonder i wonder why this is just
the first time we've heard of it though
this is this is the issue the left is
organized and so the city says we'll
give you whatever you want
right and the right isn't so they don't
yeah because they're too busy working
they're too busy with their jobs trying
to figure their life out because they're
actually planning for the future it
makes sense to me squeaky wheel gets the
grease man
the people who don't want to work are
like yeah how can we how can we not work
how can we figure that out it's like
come on
well sorry you got to work to hopefully
survive in this world
yes make america again yes
the funny thing the the best thing about
goya is that it's a hispanic company
and it's like the big i think it's like
the biggest hispanic company in the
country
yeah and one of them in the world and
the left is targeting it and trump
supporters
are the ones supporting it it's like
it's all tribal men
yeah that boycott goya didn't really
work for them it was a buy car
oh what's up a buy cotton yeah yeah it
turned into a bike
people were saying their stock was going
up i think they're a private company i
don't think they have any stock
like that thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast we do
the show
live monday through friday at 8 pm if
you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you